there is a new story involving secret
service text messages related to the
trump riots that has now gone viral and
exploded i'm going to tell you what's
going on and remember just because text
messages have been erased doesn't mean
they aren't retrievable and indeed the
latest news is that the text messages
despite being deleted are going to be
retrieved so let's jump into the story
cnbc report
january 6th panel subpoena's secret
service for erased texts the house
committee investigating the us capital
attack subpoenaed the secret service for
text messages agents reportedly deleted
right around january 6 2021 the date of
the trump riots committee chairman benny
thompson said in a statement the
committee understands the messages had
been erased
thompson outlined an aggressive timeline
for the production of the documents by
tuesday that's tomorrow and i'll tell
you in a moment whether they are going
to have the text messages by that date
the guardian reports january 6th
committee to receive deleted secret
service texts according to democrat
agencies account of how texts sent on
capital attack and day before were lost
has shifted several times when you get
different explanations for the same
occurrence it's not proof that someone
is lying but it's at least a suggestion
that you should be looking into what the
hell is going on
uh deleted secret service text sent on
january 6 the day of the insurrection at
the u.s capitol
will be released by tuesday to the house
committee
you can imagine how shocked we were to
get the letter from the department of
homeland security inspector general
saying he'd been trying to get this
information and they had in fact been
deleted after he asked for them said zoe
lofgren to uh abc's this week we need
all the texts to get the full picture
this is the interesting part
the secret services account about how
text messages from the day before and
the day of the capital attack were a
race has shifted several times at one
point the explanation from the secret
service for the lost texts was because
of software upgrades according to the
inspector general at another point the
explanation was because of device
replacements
the inspector general also said that
though the secret service opted to have
his office do a review of the agency's
response to the capital attack in lieu
of conducting after-action reports it
then stonewalled the review by slow
walking production materials there were
claims during the trump administration
that even the secret service which is
widely i don't know if widely considered
but widely expected to be an apolitical
organization
involved only in protecting
individuals in positions of power
including the president their family and
others even though that's the idea
the allegations
during the trump presidency were that
even secret service had turned political
and that there were essentially trump
hacks within secret service maybe not at
the highest levels but at medium and
agent levels
if indeed
that was the case it would make sense
that they would all of a sudden
be wanting to be very cloudy about what
took place on january 5th and january 6
particularly now in light of cassidy
hutchinson's claims before the committee
that trump tried to get secret service
to take him to the capitol for the riot
that trump tried to commandeer a vehicle
that trump lunged at a secret service
agent and on and on and on so the
circumstantial case would give us a
number of reasons to suspect why the
secret service might just just not have
accidentally deleted the exact test
texts that were requested as of this
morning deleted secret service texts to
be sent to january 6 committee by
tuesday tomorrow so it does appear as
though the secret service texts uh will
be turned over
and on thursday night is what is at
least for now considered to be
the last uh january 6th hearing we will
see what role these text messages play
then you really can't make this stuff up
now
remember as we're learning here deleted
and retrievable are two different things
and if you zoom out for a moment and
think about january 5 january 6th
trump's daily visitor and call log has
that very suspicious seven hour gap
talked about that months ago
mike pence didn't want to get into the
car with secret service when the rioters
were getting into the house the uh
capitol and they were chanting hang mike
pence and a gallows had been built
pence was hesitant to get into the car
with secret service why exactly we don't
know and now we have the allegation and
it seems to be proven that secret
service texts were deleted look at the
pattern
extraordinarily odd extraordinarily
bizarre and in the next 72 to 96 hours
we may have more insights into exactly
what is in those text messages let me
know what you expect find me on twitter
at dpakman we'll take a quick break and
be right back
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chile sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro they're all water-based
temperature controlled pads that fit
onto your existing mattress you can keep
your bed as low as 55 degrees as hot as
115 degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 percent off of the
uhler and cube sleep systems and 10 off
the new doc pro this offer is only for
my audience the link is down below